we all want to go to the gym and get
swole but how many of us have had
accidents in the gym i'm about to
diagnose them
[Music]
running running right oh
that was a slide tackle red card just ah
that's part of the exercise you gotta
escape the thing you gotta do a quick
counter movement jump
bench bench bench strong bench oh can't
get it up i say if you're alone in the
gym it's better to not use clips so that
in a situation like this you can throw
the weight off to the side obviously you
got to be ready because it's going to
flick to the other side as well see
what's going to happen here oh don't
choke yourself out yeah this is a really
big problem because you could start
putting pressure on your veins here and
actually cut off your circulation to
your brain but putting pressure on the
veins is a little bit easier because
they're thin walled so you start
building up pressure in your brain and
that could make you pass out on its own
wow so so dangerous here i hope he's
safe
okay what's about to happen is he gonna
glide over the water glide over the
water glide over the water oh oh oh oh
honestly those rapid kind of changes of
direction terrible on your joints like
the knee
i just felt the acl scream like the
person screen but that person was merely
speaking for the acl
okay parkour part
or was it ready for that oh my god he's
gonna have to visit a dentist a nasal
surgeon he's not gonna breathe well he's
probably gonna have to drink smoothies
for a while
ow
i felt that no real injury but pain
yeah oh
what is happening here honestly like
i've seen weird stuff at the gym before
like people just misusing equipment but
i've never seen stuff like this
my hamstring is literally jealous of
that flexibility
okay more people misusing machines
interesting that gentleman was very much
interested in her form
whoa that is a lot a lot of lumbosacral
flexibility whoa
that is he's a contortionist okay
oh cirque du soleil okay so that makes
sense there's blood vessels called the
vertebral arteries that run uh up and
down either end of your spine you're
gonna put a lot of pressure on those by
being in that hyper-extended position i
wonder like is he cutting off
circulation to his lower extremities
right now i was just doing leg press and
watch what happens
what happened
i now have king guys
okay not how you get pink eye pink eye
is usually a viral condition sometimes
bacterial why did she have to come up
like this i hope they know each other
because if they don't this is an awkward
way to get to know one another it's like
well
hello crotch
shoulder circles oh front facing squat
oh two
oh
that's there's a lot of strength
involved in that
a lot of strength
medically that looked tangled
when you accidentally get to hyped for
the homies pr
to me if you did that to my back i would
just cough maybe because i'm elderly now
dunk
oh
double fail double fail
[Music]
okay we got oh oh
oh that is so dangerous that is why
those machines have to be secured to the
ground especially if you're using
resistance bands because imagine if hit
him in the back of the head knocked him
unconscious then he fell with it man
that could have been deadly
oh wow he's struggling with that
he's struggling whoa oh he's getting
really red this is raising the
intracranial pressure
[Music]
oh shut down
you know what could happen here he could
have a vasovagal response where he
actually bear down too hard dilated all
his blood vessels in his legs therefore
dropping the blood pressure not getting
enough circulation to his brain and then
that's why when he went down he started
feeling better because then it was
easier for the heart to circulate that
blood from the lower extremities
whoa throw up jerk nope oh oh went too
far back i love that this guy completely
didn't care he was just like oh yeah
you're good rub some dirt
oh oh he knocked himself out
oh i dubs idubbbz may 14th the chin
worst place to get hit because you get
the maximal rotation and movement of the
brain inside the skull because remember
the brain sits in a soup so when he gets
shaken like that you could easily get
knocked out
no excuses oh one legged let's go
let's go
let's go dead lifting yeah look at that
hamstring activation
that rear chain posterior chain good
stuff fella oh what is this real
first of all the balance on this is
incredible to dip with that much weight
on you i mean what is it 315 his triceps
and shoulders my god i wouldn't
recommend that
oh my god look at these tires i'm sorry
i have worked out before but i have no
idea what the preset weights for tires
are so that could be literally like 50
pounds or it could be 5 000 pounds i
don't know
does it mean this person can lift a semi
imagine their name is axel
oh
medial ankle injury like that
bone
oh my god you get struck on the bone on
one side that could potentially be a
fracture of bone bruise but then you
also evert your ankle therefore putting
strain on the anterior talofibular
anterior
then he fell onto the assault bike 10
month bulk update my son's bulk is going
really well but we tried to introduce
ball sports and he got a bit confused he
does the occasional assisted squat which
he loves so i did some tinkering in the
garage with a bunch of scraps and built
him a fully custom quarter sized leg
press that's so cute he loves it and
he's gonna have some monster quads and
glutes soon that's adorable please don't
make the baby over lift but that was
really cute hope the baby doesn't get a
splinter either this guy's uh really
looking thin on those legs maybe that's
because the form is just absolutely what
is going on is he dancing is this zumba
zuma squats what is happening here this
is what happens when you load up the
thing to look cool for your girl you
really have no idea what you're doing
okay this is a cat with toilet paper
just chilling i would have done this
better i would have thrown a toilet
paper on the tail as well and watched it
move what'd i just watch
whoa that's savage how does he know how
does he know god if that hits
tooth gone
okay ship sliding off very aesthetically
pleasing oh not aesthetically pleasing
oh nope still less likely pleasing
oh i know something's gonna go wrong
here he's with the ab wheel and he's on
the dumbbell and those are unstable
dumbbells they're not heavy enough to be
stable oh
fracture tooth fracture tooth dislodge
tooth fractured jaw oh just terrible why
would you do that for the gram he did it
for the oh plyo apply wow balance and
plyo
wow he can do three
wow that's really really impressive like
you guys have no idea how hard that is
props bro
okay what do we got here lots of plates
the bar is bending so you know it's
really heavy
okay good form
is the bar about to break
drop it bro
drop it
wow that is a bad barbell that's really
bad this gentleman is strong he got
lucky there
[Music]
whoa
that is so dangerous god that thing
could cut the other guy's face
lacerations terrible
[Music]
whoa okay that's gotta be a skit that's
gotta be a skit that is way too evil you
could really hurt yourself like that
quick hands quick feet
she's in socks she was quit yo you see
me box i'm not as good as that
the stiff arm
niners
niners
oh
wow look at that
cowbell more cowbell please i gotta have
more cowbells oh it's bear hey bear you
throw bear in a little nugget
wow that's a good
bear oh they're using sound to guide the
hoop
boom with the backboard banks open on
tuesday folks thanks open on tuesdays
folks
how many monsters i drink in a week
because apparently i drink too much
monday
whoa
[Music]
five in a day
this is way too much way too much i
predict kidney stones or and or kidney
problems as the first sign may be
inflammatory enzymes of the liver going
up come on mom
let go let go that's a friction burn in
a place i don't want a friction burn
oh he got clipped right in the face i'm
not a huge fan of pressing down on your
heels and lifting your butt off of the
bench some people say that this allows
them to target the lower portion of the
chest i think that if you want to do
that do a decline bench and the fact
that he's wearing those wrist supporters
at such a light weight tells me that
he's probably benching too much you
can't allow one part of your body to
become over developed and think that
everything is going to be okay you are
bound to have an injury if your wrists
are not strong enough to hold the weight
and you have to put something
artificially here this is not i'm not
talking about like strong men or like
these extreme weights as an as an
average lifter it means you best be
working on those risks instead of using
that and lower the weight
what's harder med school or law school
we debate it right here with the legal
eagle click here to check that out as
always stay happy and healthy in the gym
[Music]